bien alors on va est ce que les odeurs
en urss a montré mois d hinwil pour
pasqua il dit je les les truands de
tanger sont connus nous a dit nous les
arrêterons quand nous le voudrons il le
croquant un formidablement pasqua c'est
formidable
claude marie vadrot vous avez emmené de
force pauvre cabut en urss surtout qui
m'a fait prendre l'avion avait en plus
récemment c'est la deuxième fois il
voulait pas il a pris le tramway
oui je les emmenais de on2 force il y
avait dans une curiosité jusqu'à but de
huit ans qu'il entendait parler comme
beaucoup de gens de l'urss il a voulu un
peu voir et il s'est dit qu'avec un
guide qui connaissait un peu y aurait
les chances de dépasser la surface des
choses d'aller au delà des grands hôtels
et des tous les clichés qu'on peut
travailler sur sur ce puits et
finalement il l'a pas regretté il est
venu une fois il est venu deux fois il
venu trois fois aux assises a fait trois
voyages
mais comme vous êtes toujours en train
de faire des croquis vous n'avez vous
n'êtes pas paru très suspect très vite
non vous êtes selon les monuments en
train de sauf devant un un bateau de
guerre à leningrad là un flic en civil
qui est venu nous dire d'aller plus loin
mais non alors vous comment ça se passe
vous vous noté sur un carnet et lui
dessine
nous avons chacun carnet de notes et
fébrile et le chrono tourne aux
impressions et l'autre il faut dire que
l'un claude marie vadrot lui connaît il
va tous les quinze jours
je connais ce pays comme sa poche donc
ces quelques façades sud rail pour le
kgb
non je travaille pour quelque chose qui
est beaucoup plus menacé que le kgb
c'est le matin l'un n'empêche pas
l'autre
oui effectivement mais oui et si je
travaille vraiment intéressé on leur a
donné quelques sous pour le mot
malheureux journal bah oui j'espère je
n'ai rien vu venir
après on a de bonnes nouvelles de votre
journal de meilleures nouvelles mans
très bien bengtsson - jouit tous donc le
cas but il ya une chose qui n'est qu'à
but mais alors tout le long du livre
tout dans ses dessins
c'est que les russes ans notamment les
enfants sont en train de sa mairie
cannes ise et il n'a jamais entendu
autant de rock qu en urss et le rox vous
est insupportable c'est vrai
ouais ils sont foutus sont foutus comme
nous on est foutu par la culture
américaine lah va rejoindre je vais
rejoindre agents commis mais je pense
que c'est pas c'est in fine fine comme
on dit un cul de sac quoi le rock ça ne
débouchera sur rien mais enfin ça et
comment expliquez-vous qu'ils aiment ça
parce que parce qu'ils sont ils sont
allés coûte de l'occident quand même
tout ils sentent que enfin ils sont des
illusions s'ils croient que c'est un
pays formidable
ah c'est vrai que c'est mieux bon mais
mais culturellement ils avaient des
richesses qui sont en train de
s'éteindre
mais bon non seulement le rock mais le
coca cola le pepsi cola
les livres de raquel welch et jane fonda
sur la diététique la gymnastique font
fureur là-bas au jeu lensois se vend à
des prix fous ah oui chaque fois vous en
rapporter une dizaine vous un ou 2 m de
hauteur
effectivement je me fais des amis j'ai
essayé de convaincre cas vu que le rock
était une libération pour les jeunes
soviétique que c'était un progrès et
j'ai échoué il pleut je suis en national
c'est tout à fait différent où selon le
chant depuis l'international on lui
recevait ticket de l'année a non mais
vous une riche vous chantez vous chantez
que dans quel est le champ qui vous
énerve tant aussi qu'il chante toujours
la danse des canards et danse des
canards le partout partout on entend ça
à la télé abondant les émissions
enfantines c'est la danse des canards
dans les hôtels pour touristes et la
danse des canards et dans le hall i do
au lido de moscou c'est la danse des
canards
c'est formidable et participer au défilé
du 1er mai je me suis glissée dans un
groupe qui défilait sur la place rouge
il ya quelques semaines pour mon journal
est un carrefour avant la place rouge y
avait un orchestre amateur payés par la
municipalité et qui jouait la danse des
canards
mais je crois que le fait remarquer
c'est que cabu et les vieux du parti
même combat absolument ils détestent ils
détestent la jeunesse soviétique il
disait malraux qui n'aiment pas leur
colle voilà mais je regrette qu'ils nous
aient pas pris le jazz plutôt voyez ça
moi j'aime le jazz j'avais pas le rock
c'est pour ça ben non il est pas le lie
à une boîte de jazz qui s'est ouvert il
ya quelques jours dans la rue gorki
de mousse pour vous annoncer la fin du
stakhanovisme fini ça canalise alors
écouter le discours de gorbatchev hier
au comité central il en est assez plein
il a dit à mort ça qu'à 9oo il a dit
vous êtes tous des fainéants vous ne
faites lurio abus il veut qu'on revienne
à sa canne alors là lui souhaiterait le
plein dans les rues ce qu'on se remette
un peu au travail parce que vous dites
ceci est la formule est amusante métro
boulot coco c'est un fantasme
d'occidental je crois que les ruches
d'une part les soviétiques ont inventé
une espèce de civilisation de loisirs
c'est à dire qu'ils travaillent très peu
ils sont pas énormément pm il travaille
très peu et finalement ils ne s'en
plaignent pas et quand on leur propose
des réformes comme actuellement qu'est
ce qu'il voit on leur demande pour le
même prix travailler un peu plus et doit
être un peu plus efficace et il voit pas
il veut pas l'intérêt il faut les
comprendre ils préfèrent aller à la
pêche l'été faire du ski l'hiver fait
pendant les jo à la scène le week-end à
ils ont inventé le week-end ça y est ils
ont pris le mot week end au vocabulaire
franco-américain ils nous ont pris en
fin ils ont pu remercier le mot business
qui a été totalement intégré à la langue
russe
oui mais cela ils sont fascinés par sa
terreur les russes nous je le comprends
un peu je vous promets je leur parle un
peu comprends bien il faut valdir je
suis pas censé comprendre les faits la
bla avons pas m'accuser moi je suis
désolé nous les casser votre coup là
absolue bon autre information quand même
du capital c'est que le baiser viril des
hommes sur la bouche d'homme à homme est
en train de disparaître sauf les
militaires ah bon ah oui avec leurs
médailles s'embrassant sur la bouche
deux militaires de balles terne comme m
le jeune héros du film événement de
gorbatchev a effectivement supprimés
apparemment le le baiser viril et
d'ailleurs il ya une photo qui est parue
dans la presse où on voyait le vieux
gros mytho qui avait embrassé des
générations secrétaires généraux faire
comme ça à l'aéroport et oui car
gorbatchev lui tendant la main il est
resté quand cette exposition est
effectivement on ya pensé wind ronces à
craindre le sida et les inquiétudes dans
ce domaine je sais pas si vous avez
passé le dépasse que votre dernier
dessin on voit gorbatchev échangeant un
baiser viril avec françois mitterrand je
passais en laser
voilà voilà alors lui superbe ce dessin
c'est le dernier d'ailleurs il est
absolument
enfin ça c'est une invention voulait pas
lui c'est la seule chose qu'on a vu des
choses qu'il n'y ait pas dans le livre
il ya un autre baiser des des fameux
militaire qu'on avait vus à l'aéroport
d'ailleurs de moscou s'offrir des fleurs
jaunes aliments animaux
qu'est ce que jean coquet sous pensé de
leur voyage de ce récit ses croquis est
un peu accablant pour lurs bon c'est pas
s'est passé s'est pas passé de l'ours
mais c'est vraiment une estocade
extraordinairement fine et subtile et
cruel mais en même temps on veut montrer
qu'on les aime bien mais il mérite
d'être connu et payeur est trop
négligent les jambons le réveil s'est
pas d'anti soviétisme primaire n'ont
pourtant pas ce qui fait qu'on vous dise
quand même connu notre net n'étions des
communistes à aucun moment de notre vie
donc on a on n'a rien on n'a pas de rien
à prouver on a pas de vieille
2 les images et on a effacé sa ligne
regrets ça jamais été notre idéal notre
modèle du reste du réseau ferré oui
nucera coup de mou oui je me suis amusé
à lire je pense c'est surtout pour les
communistes français que c'est terrible
parce que les communistes soviétiques ne
pas en avoir beaucoup
alors ceux qui quoi par exemple un
personnage de la fée franchement plus
mais de nombreux autres personnages de
la faim qui essaye d'expliquer le
service est la faute des z'arts s'ils
sont si l'on à ce niveau je pense que
c'est assez triste
y'a que les communistes français qui
sont persuadés qu'il ya encore beaucoup
de communistes aux murs tristes non mais
c'est un autre gros fait carrière comme
onfray carrière au parti socialiste tout
est refait vous écoutent oui mon avis je
l'aï mais déjà et alors eh bien monsieur
vadrot nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec
tout mais nous avons bien